it's a chilly misty morning in Guatemala
the latest group of travelers hope
Mexico in the United States gather at a
secret location they're being smuggled
by a crime gang a syndicate with a
network throughout South and Central
America and stretching right into the
United States the group is escaping the
gang violence and poverty of Nicaragua
El Salvador and Honduras or want to make
a new start in life this they think is
the best way but their journey is
fraught with danger
this unmarked mountain crossing has
never been filmed before it's taken
months for Sky News to get permission
from the traffickers cartel bosses on
board our two young girls Daniela is 16
carla is 40
[Music]
they seem unaware how vulnerable they
are how much danger they're in there
dude bit that they and their families
are concerned are you scared of this
trip are the family scared
see we fell upon a s primera vez que
Viejo e familia
nunca hemos Toledo police purpose for
chaos allele for cable a post porque no
sense in los voy a volver aware
what has driven you to move and you're
very young so what does driven it now
[Music]
por que tenga miss a renewed Ock
this is not the name of para comer Sen
falta la comida y hace falta de niro yo
yo yo salir de mio gar para oír who said
Carlos adelante you to me in circus the
pequeña pero la fourmi familia quiero
get okay think I'm gonna make her a vida
is it safer for everyone to travel
together in a group like this this man
is the group's guide all the way to the
United States the guides are called
coyotes he's a gang member
crucially he has the phone numbers and
passwords to get past the dozens of
gangs that lie ahead of them there is no
guarantee they will be safe CSS kucik in
Mexico muy peligroso
pero CASL trata con un hoyo de que tiene
contactos en todo mexico my problema
porque el coyote save our reportando con
la mafia judicial federal my grassy oh
no no see the simple fact is that almost
all people attempting this journey are
touched by violent crime in some form
robbery and assault are almost
guaranteed the rape and abduction of
young girls and their subsequent
imprisonment in brothels is so common
the crimes aren't even investigated
almost all of the girls working the
streets in the Mexican border town at a
petula where virtually all migrants pass
started their professional life still
dreaming of an ordinary life in the
United States Karolina is typical she
crossed the Mexican border trying to get
to the United States within minutes she
was abducted by a man offering her a
lift it was the start of a life of
prostitution wandering greasy a la
Frontera de Guatemala con Mexico fellow
primero campus office lugar you know
Sevilla please you me Wendy Aaron ie 2 o
que pagar por todo que pagar well Teresa
Claro no to a que pagar Joe my friend
and persona routine and when you say you
were sold you arrived at a building and
people basically you were then
imprisoned and and you couldn't leave
without what happened that's okay para
el dinero que vea milk a cauliflower and
have that have you gone beyond that now
you feel better now
Mosca Thorley with it the sheer numbers
of people risking everything even death
chasing the dream of a new life in the
United States has turned into a global
epidemic the trafficking syndicate
promising a cure to endemic poverty and
violence in countries around the world
are simply profiteering from the desire
for a better life
we know these girls made it to Mexico we
were with them but where they are now we
don't know and we probably never will
they could now just be another statistic
of trafficking crime stewar am G Sky
News Mexico